birth control gives people license to
express themselves sexually in a free
manner and many people are opposed to
that hi I'm Nick Gillespie for Reason TV
and today we're talking with Peter bag
the great cartoonist he's got a new
expanded hardcover version of everybody
is stupid except for me and other astute
observations as well as a brand new
biography of Margaret Sanger the birth
control pioneer called woman rebel what
made Margaret Sanger interesting to you
well everything about her is interesting
she's led an amazing life and and also
I'm very much in support of her life's
mission which is contraceptive
information for all you wouldn't think
that at one point that was controversial
but it was something it was a message
that she was frequently imprisoned for
also did I very much want to do the book
in part to correct some widely held
misconceptions about yeah because Margot
Sanger is obviously highly controversial
even today a lot of people say that she
was in favor of eugenics that she was a
racist what is the biggest misconception
about Margaret Sanger and how do you
address that in the in woman rebel well
probably the first and foremost is
sometimes there's even a meme online
that she is the quote-unquote inventor
of abortion and the surprising truth is
that she was a lifelong opponent of our
abortion or a whole life now I myself am
pro-choice she never was in that regard
she always for both moral reasons and
medical reasons opposed abortion the
ironic thing about that is many of these
negative notions that are being
perpetrated on the internet about her
are being perpetrated largely by
pro-life groups and they're based there
basically you're doing it to demonize
the nominal founder of Planned
Parenthood right which is Sanger Sanger
and it's more complicated you get into
it a bit in the book she's not she's a
founder of Planned Parenthood of what
became Planned Parenthood but she's not
in favor of abortion what about the
eugenics charge the idea that she was in
favor of sterilizing or keeping unfit
people from reproducing well that's a
really tough one to answer just because
of the way eugenics over the last 50 or
so years has become an increasingly is
becoming very narrowly defined as almost
not almost synonymous with fascism and
nazism and basically being in favor of
killing or sterilizing people who were
considered less than and and kind of
like a state based program of who gets
to repro procreate and who doesn't
exactly where is during the Progressive
Era especially the 1920s when the
eugenic thought was at its peak it the
the it was much more wide raging than
that there were very many people who did
believe in it along very specific racial
lines but basically the word means good
genes and it's the idea was simply to in
any way you could think of it in a wider
sense it was all about improving the
human condition making sure the next
generation is healthier and smarter than
yours was many leading eugenicist s-- at
the time wish that she had nothing to do
with eugenics or wish that she wouldn't
try to ride on their coattails which she
was rather she was doing for self
promotional reasons she wanted to give
the birth control movement more academic
legitimacy she was trying to appeal in
her own words I was trying to reach out
to the men of science because back then
birth control the entire subject was
considered very sordid and unseemly and
and it was essentially illegal in most
contexts to distribute literature about
birth containing information about birth
control was completely illegal the
extent to which she could be associated
in any way shape or form with the now
negative aspects of eugenics is and this
is the most extreme thing I've ever read
of hers is that she wouldn't rule out
forced sterilization in extreme
situations in extreme in her case would
be how she would define that is
destitute woman who is you know like
extremely mentally incapacitated and
either her or her family have any way of
raising a child and yet without birth
control information there
or access to it she would keep having
babies that would become Ward's of the
state by default
still she she always would point out the
slippery slope that that would lead to
so she was she would only talk about
that when I was addressed and this
wasn't in the 1920s this was not an
extreme position to take though in the
book you make a strong case that what
Margaret Sanger ultimately was really
about was sexual autonomy for all people
but especially women who were denied it
do you think that her goals have largely
been achieved in today's society yes to
an extreme degree absolutely and all for
the better I am sympathetic to people
who are against abortion how they
perceive it as murder or some type of
murder I can understand that I'm
sympathetic to that but for an awful lot
of people to the rapid opposition to it
is part of this much deeper rooted
opposition to birth control and that has
a lot to do with wanting to control
other people's behaviors birth control
gives people license to express
themselves sexually in a free manner and
many people are opposed to that oddly to
me it's all part of this strange
compulsion that I would say most humans
have to micromanage other people's lives
it's all about controlling other
people's lives and denying them more
time to be just too fearing that with
that autonomy they would only they would
only do regrettable things
thank you Peter bag the new book is
woman rebel the Margaret Sanger story
it's out from drawn and quarterly now in
hardcover there is also a new edition a
hardcover expanded edition of his great
collection of Reason work plus some
everybody is stupid except for me Peter
thanks for talking to us sure thank you